oui
mes chers compatriotes le véritable
enjeu de l'élection présidentielle c'est
le bien-être des français
votre bien-être et la condition de ce
bien-être
c'est la réussite et la grandeur de la
france
tout le monde vous parle de justice
sociale c'est bien mais pour réaliser la
justice sociale il faut que la france
créent les richesses nécessaires et donc
gagnent la bataille économique que j'ai
engagé il y a deux ans est aussi que
chaque français et sa juste part des
fruits de la réussite
l'enjeu de l'élection présidentielle
n'est pas de savoir qui va gagner et du
peuple de gauche ou du peuple de droite
il s'agit de choisir entre la france qui
perd et la france qui gagne
pour tous les français
de 1981 à 1986 sous l' empire des
socialistes notre pays a pris cinq ans
de retard sur ses voisins et sur ses
concurrents ne vous y trompez pas
socialisme aujourd'hui même s'il ne veut
plus dire son nom
même si son candidat déclare ne pas
avoir de programme n'en est pas pour
autant moins dangereux depuis deux ans
j'ai entrepris le redressement de la
france et les premiers résultats sont là
je croise à la sagesse de mes
compatriotes
il s'agit juger sur les actes et ne se
contente pas de bonnes paroles pour que
la france gagne
voici ce qu'il faut faire et si vous me
fait confiance je le ferai
il faut achever de remettre l'état à sa
vraie place
réduire les déficits et les endettements
il faut donner plus de liberté et
d'initiatives aux citoyens et donner aux
entreprises la possibilité de se
développer pour
dire et créer des emplois il faut
maintenir la protection sociale est
donné à tous jeunes et moins jeunes par
l'éducation et par la formation la
première dignité de l'homme avoir un
travail il faut repenser la politique
familiale et donner enfin aux femmes la
liberté d'élever leurs enfants et
d'avoir une activité professionnelle
il faut garantir la sécurité pour tous
et ne pas transiger sur la défense de la
france et sa place dans le monde
il faut définir ensemble une politique
de l'immigration qui respecte à la fois
notre identité nationale
et bien entendu les droits de l'homme
quand on croit comme je crois au génie
de la france on ne peut pas accepter et
je n'accepte pas qu'un français hommes
ou femmes restent sur le bord de la
route parce que à 55 ans il a perdu son
emploi parce qu'ils les seules ou âgées
ou handicapées il ne suffit pas que la
collectivité se donnent bonne conscience
en distribuant seulement des allocations
il faut aller au devant de ceux qui ont
besoin de nous et les aider à trouver ou
à retrouver leur place toute leur place
dans notre société
mais nous ne pourrons gagner ensemble
que si la france retrouve son rang en
europe car c'est là que je joue notre
destin elle était la première il ya 20
ans par son dynamisme
elle peut le redevenir et il le faut
cela ne dépend que de vous et du choix
que vous ferez le 24 avril et le 8 mai
et de toutes mes forces et de tout mon
coeur je veux faire de la france pour
chacun d'entre nous un pays
plus fort plus libre plus juste mieux
rassembler et plus fraternelle
il